Hello there. We're glad that you all came. We're thrilled with the turnout. We know it's a beautiful night, and we know it's kind of a long walk, so we apologize if you don't always know where they're going to put us if we haven't been here.
So we appreciate you're coming. My name is Jane. We represent the Upper Room Wellness Center, and we're in Venice Heights, Minnesota on the eastern edge of the Twin Cities, and we absolutely love what we do.
We don't just do product line. We also do alternative cancer, and if you want to see hope, it's our company. We laugh and have fun while we're getting better, and we love it.
I just wanted to quickly tell you a story, because I think it isn't just about all the information that you get, but it's about recognizing that each person is an individual, and each person has their own story and their own difficult time.
It's a difficult time when it's been by cancer that they're dealing with. We also do brain-based therapy. I'm working on it right now because we have therapy that can help not so that you won't get dimensioned all-timers, so I'm working on that right now and I love it.
We just tell you a shared ill story. Her mom called me one day from Ottawa, Canada, and she said, Jane, my daughter is bedridden. She's been sick for 20 years, and we've been to everyone.
And we don't know what is wrong, and she said, I went to my doctor, and he said, well, I'll tell you if I had anything, I would go to the States, and I'd go to Minnesota, and I'd see Dr. Commerce.
We don't even know who he is, but a shared ill mom called me, and we scheduled on an appointment, and she came to us.
And when she pulled up to our clinic, and her mom actually had to help her walk into the clinic, you just looked at her and the plight looked awful.
And you just had that glass over the look, you know, when you're in pain and you don't feel good, you probably all know someone or are one of those that just had a difficult time.
Well, she came, and she started with us, and went back to Ottawa, Canada, and came back in four months, and when she walked in her door, I could not believe it was the same person.
Her mom started to cry, and she said, this is who my daughter is, and she was so much better, she's just continued to get better, better, she's back to work, she has three kids at home, so it was difficult for her.
But we love this story because there's great hope, and we love being able to help people, each one, like I said, that comes as an individual.
And I don't want to take that time because I know that's what you came for, but I want you to know that people are individuals, and that we are there to help people.